Again quickly reviewing because
this is so key to what follows.
US healthcare is highly uncoordinated
because so many specialized physicians
are involved in the care of patients
with multiple chronic diseases.
One reason is that we have
such a small percentage,
only around 12% of
primary care physicians.
Other countries, such as Australia,
France and Canada,
have around 50% of
primary care physicians.
The resulting problems
are not theoretical.
The more physicians they see, 4 or
more versus 1 to 2 physicians,
more chronic disease patients
report being seen by a physician
with an incomplete or missing record.
There's similar data for medical errors.